Speaker 1: All right.
So here's what I have been building to with
this Trump getting booed for suggesting people
get vaccinated at his Alabama rally for months
now, really since the 2012 election, we've
been talking about how can we deprogram these
trumpets?
How can we bring tens of millions of people
back to having some semblance of a connection
with reality and so that they can be meaningful
participants in American society rather than
just people getting in the way that we have
to sort of get around in order to get anything
done.
And we haven't been able to figure it out.
And normally in history, when you look at
when there have been massive shifts in public
consciousness, when you look at massive cultural
shifts, massive when when things happen that
quickly, usually it's because some dictator
has come in and imposed an authoritarian,
dictatorial government.
One of the greatest examples of this is the
Chinese Cultural Revolution, where you had
it wasn't that people's views just evolved
naturally, really quickly.
It was that you had a dictatorial, authoritarian
government come in and say, this is the new
culture.
That is not likely to happen in the United
States, so and that's good.
And so absent that, the question we've been
asking is how do we bring these people back?
And I really thought a lot about this during
my trip to Europe from which I came back last
week because I was just in a place without
trumpets for a little bit.
And it sort of gave me some context.
And my feeling is increasingly these people
are too far gone.
They can't be brought back.
Now, I'm not throwing in the towel.
I still think we continue to talk about it
and figure this out.
But I do believe that for the most part, these
people are too far gone.
And then the cherry on top, I think, was at
the rally Saturday night in Alabama, where
Trump says to his own sycophants, I mean,
there's no greater suck ups for Trump than
the people that spend 12 hours waiting for
him at a rally.
Trump says the vaccine is good.
Go and get it.
And then they jeer and they boo.
I mean, this is the Trump that could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue and not lose his supporters.
And he says the vaccine is good.
Go and get it.
And they boo.
And he immediately has to backtrack.
I played this clip in the segment about the
rally, but let's just look at it one more
time, three
Speaker 2: days, less than nine months.
And it's great.
And you know what?
I believe totally in your freedoms.
I do.
You got to do what you have to do.
But I recommend take the vaccines.
I did it.
It's good.
Take the vaccines.
But you got.
That's OK, Tara.
You got your freedoms.
But I happen to take the vaccine.
If it doesn't work, you'll be the first to
know.
OK, I'll call up Alabama and say, hey, you
know what?
But it is working.
But you do have your freedoms.
You have to keep you have to maintain that.
You have to maintain that.
And you got to get your kids back to school.
Speaker 1: That sort of like game, set, match
for me, guys.
I mean, I'm ready to declare it.
These people are too far gone to be brought
back at the mass scale level.
Now, at some micro level, we regularly hear,
you know, I've been working on my crazy cousin
for four, four months and now they've changed
their mind.
That can happen.
But at a mass scale, I don't know that we're
bringing these people back.
And so Trump has really lost control of his
own monster.
If he can't control it, nobody can.
I use the analogy earlier of you get a protection
dog and it's so aggressive, it's dangerous
even to the owner.
It's trying to protect you, lose control of
the dog.
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein isn't.
You know that these are these are the thoughts
that I'm having.
And as I asked earlier, I think this is the
if correct me if I'm wrong, I think this is
the first time a rally crowd has actually
booed something that Donald Trump said.
And Trump really needed to be promoting the
vaccine in a more real way before he left
office between January 6th and January 20th.
Not as I'm great because I got us the vaccine
and Biden will screw it up.
But just everybody get it.
It's safe.
It's effective.
It wasn't really available while Donald Trump
was still in office, but it's just too late
for that.
The damage was done and it shouldn't really
surprise us that now his own crowd boos him
when he says get vaccinated because Trump
refused to wear a mask in twenty twenty.
He called it the China virus and a hoax.
And Trump continued to do all of the things
that would encourage people ultimately not
to get vaccinated.
And I don't think we can get him back at this
point in time.
So sanity in the American right wing returning,
if we ever had it, is going to depend on young
people who aren't yet political.
Now, hopefully we can pull those people left,
but if they end up on the right, maybe they
would be not crazy like these.
Trump that's non Trump Republicans who maybe
can grow their share of the party.
But I don't know that these tens of millions
of people can be brought back.
Trump broke them and even he can't fix them.
And that's really crazy.
The vaccine now exists in this other America,
almost like this mark of the beast that they
talk about.
And some wrote to me saying, David, don't
worry about it.
It's Darwinian, but it's really not, first
of all, because many of those people already
had kids and some of them even brought their
kids to this rally.
Darwinian would be some trait that's disadvantageous
to reproduction.
But a lot of these people have already reproduced.
And then as far as the vaccines go, as I mentioned
earlier, I suspect one of the most effective
ways to get these people to get vaccinated
would be you say health care companies say
if you are unvaccinated and you need covid
treatment, you don't pay a copay.
You straight up pay 50 percent of what it
costs.
And that can be tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of dollars.
I think that gets a bunch of these people
to become vaccinated.
But in some sense, a lot of this makes perfect
sense that this is the way they would feel
at this point, because for the last 18 months,
they were told covid is not real or it's real,
but it's not serious.
We don't need to change anything about our
day to day.
The vaccines may not work.
The vaccine is experimental, Joe Biden will
force vaccinations.
The vaccine might kill you, it might magnetize
you all this different stuff.
And now, you know, in late August of twenty,
twenty one, Trump says the vaccine is good.
Go and get it.
In some sense, of course, they booed.
What happens next?
I have no idea.
If you think these people are not too far
gone, I want to hear from you and tell me
exactly how we bring them back to reality.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find The David Pakman Show.